so I have an expression here three times
the entire expression 5x plus 6 and then
plus the expression 7x plus 2 and all of
that times 4 what I encourage you to do
is pause this video and see if you can
simplify this expression I'll give you a
hint you're gonna have to do some
distribution and then some combining of
like terms all right now I'm assuming
you've had a go at it now let's let's
work through this together
so as I mentioned when I see this 3
times the entire expression 5x plus 6 I
want to distribute that 3 so I want to
multiply that 3 times 5x and that 3
times the 6 so 3 times 5x well if I have
five X's and I'll have 3 times that I'm
going to have 15 X's and then 3 times 6
is 18 so this part of the expression we
have now simplified to 15 X plus 18 now
let's do the next part so here I have I
have this larger expression written
before this 4 but I want to do the same
thing I just want to distribute the 4 it
doesn't matter whether I'm multiplying
if I have the 3 of have the number on
the left side or on the right side so
let's distribute this 4 I want to do 4
times 7x and I want to do 4 times 2 4
times 7x well that's going to be 28 X 28
X and then 4 times 2 is going to be 8 so
we're almost there this part of our
expression has simplified to 28 X plus 8
and now we can combine we can combine
similar terms so we have 15 X's and then
we can add that to 28 X's so if I had 15
let me do this in a different color if I
have 15 of something and I add 28 of
something of that same something to it
well then I'm going to have what 43 X's
so 43 X is 15 X plus 28 X's I added the
coefficients there that's going to be 43
X's and then 18 plus 8 let me do this in
a new color so 18 plus 8 is going to be
26 and we're done we've simplified this
longer expression we did some
distribution then we combined some
terms to get 43 X plus 26